c'est ici dans deux logements vacants de
la commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
canastasia sa fille d'un an sa soeur
marina et ses nièces toutes ukrainienne
ont démarré une nouvelle vie depuis mars
2022 c'est très difficile parce que
et maintenant un corps
je ne peux je ne peux croire que c'est
que c'est vrai Anastasia et Marina ont
dû dire au revoir à leur mari leurs
enfants et leurs parents qui sont restés
en Ukraine pour défendre le pays malgré
le quotidien qui peut s'avérer difficile
elle continue d'avoir des projets et ont
appris le français avec Pôle Emploi on
apprend français parce que c'est
obligatoire pour moi je peux comprendre
je peux parler avec les gens maintenant
je donnais un coffre de piano j'ai
quelques élèves je cherchais les autres
parce que je vais je peux réunir
Ukraine mais je ne suis pas
quand je peux venir il faut il faut
vivre ici je suis professeur de
plastique art et je travaille à
l'université de la fritectura et
maintenant
je vais faire aussi une ligne course
pour moi étudiants
[Musique]
musicienne Anastasia organise des
concerts caritatifs avec son ami
d'enfance Daria habitante de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux de son côté sa
soeur marina et peintre et expose ses
oeuvres pour également récolter des
fonds elles espèrent toujours pouvoir
retourner dans leur pays en Ukraine oui
j'espère que la guerre s'arrête et on va
gagner mais maintenant c'est très
dangereux parce que j'ai une petite
fille et j'ai peur pour elle les devis
de Marina ont retrouvé une école l'une
est au lycée de Villaroy à Guyancourt
l'autre suit des cours à distance à
l'Académie nationale de l'architecture
de Kiev le symbole que la vie continue
malgré la guerre